beim tödlichen crash mit einem selbst
fahrenden auto auf der schwäbischen alb
ist das passiert bei römerstein das ist
bei reutlingen da ist ein selbst
fahrendes auto in den gegenverkehr
gerast frontal und hat seinen riesigen
einen verheerenden crash ausgelöst ein
toter noch am unfallort gestorben und
neun weitere menschen sind verletzt
worden darunter ein erst eineinhalb
jähriges mädchen
ein autonom fahrendes auto ein
teilautonomen fahrendes auto soll also
diesen unfall ausgelöst haben solch ein
modell etwa ein bmw x5 elektrisch ein
auto eben das autonom fahren kann also
theoretisch komplett auf autopilot und
das soll sich dort um ein testfahrzeug
gehandelt haben und auf dieser testfahrt
offenbar auf autopilot wie kann das
schon ganz richtig gesagt habt steht
dann ein mensch und neun weitere werden
verletzt wir wollen darüber sprechen mit
unserem auto wirtschaften drexler vor
allem auch über dieses auto das
eventuell auf einer testfahrt oder es
könnte auch eine privatfahrt gewesen
sein diesen tragischen unfall ausgelöst
hat tom herzlich willkommen an dich
guten morgen gibt es dann nochmal ganz
andere regeln wenn sich das auto wenn es
sich bei dem auto um ein testfahrzeug
handelt ja klar gibt es er hat mich als
experten geladen deswegen ganz schnell
zu dem was vorher gesagt wurde das ist
ein auto was theoretisch teilautonomen
fahren kann autonom kann es nicht waren
autonom würde bedeuten dass es komplett
selbstständig fahren kann und der lehre
fahrer nichts mehr machen muss das kann
das auto noch nicht
aber wir wissen ja auch noch nicht ob
das überhaupt angeschaltet war oder
nicht also diese autos wenn die auf
teststrecken fahren ist es ja kein
problem das sind abgeschlossene strecken
wenn die autos auf öffentlichen wegen
unterwegs sind brauchen sie zum beispiel
vom tüv rheinland oder von anderen
organisationen eine sogenannte
ausnahmegenehmigung das heißt auf
englisch exception approval das wird
dann gegeben damit die autos in freier
strecke getestet werden können das total
wichtig ist weil man eben auch wissen
will wie die sich dann da verhalten auf
landstraßen was gegen dieses das ist ein
autonom unterwegs fahrendes auto spricht
ist das bmw sagt ja dass autos von uns
das ist ein offizielles testfahrzeug
mutmasslich der fahrer auch ein bmw
angestellt hat im auto war allerdings
noch warten noch vier weitere personen
das spricht dagegen dass man dann
irgendwelche sachen probiert das spricht
eher dafür dass das war den wagen mal
für ein paar tage übers wochenende hatte
und danach dem testen recht schreibt und
bmw sagt offiziell wir haben keinen ix
gerade fahren der autonom
autonome systeme getestet also wir sind
im moment auf level 2 level 3 ist das
level wo die autos wirklich
selbstständig fahren können also füße
von den pedalen weg hände vom lenkrad
weg und man muss auch dann nicht mehr
man muss nur bereit sein einzugreifen
aber man muss nicht alle zehn sekunden
wieder ins lenkrad greifen und solche
tests haben sie gerade nicht laufen hat
bm blieben hier erzählt wird die polizei
weiß das noch nicht die ermittelt
natürlich genau das jetzt nach diesem
tragischen nach diesem dramatischen
unfall tom erklären noch mal ganz kurz
teilautonome autonom fahren also teil
hatten bedeutete der ist theoretisch auf
autopilot ich nehme die hände vom
lenkrad fuß vom gaspedal und sitze aber
noch da kann jederzeit eingreifen genau
das ist das ist das was wir auch alle
kennen das kennen wir das ist der so
genannte spurhalteassistent da gibt's
radar vorne drin kamerasensoren also da
kann die spur automatisch halten solange
es ein streifen auf der straße gibt wenn
es dir weiße streifen dich gibt kann er
das nicht weil er braucht die streifen
und das heißt aber das ist so alle acht
sekunden gibt damit du die hände wieder
ins lenkrad machen ihr erinnert euch
sicher alle an diesen gruseligen
schrecklichen unfall 2018 mit dem uba
das war ein volvo da hat die test
fahrerin die theoretisch eingreifen
sollte wenn was schiefgeht
fernsehen geguckt auf ihrem smartphone
und dabei haben die eine fußgängerin
überfahren dies auch gestorben damals
das hat man halt alles noch im ohr
deswegen versucht man hier das besser zu
machen und die testfahrer müssen halt
immer bereit sein einzugreifen
aber wie gesagt ob in diesem auto das
überhaupt aktiviert war weiß ich nicht
spricht dagegen dass sich auf der
schwäbischen alb unterwegs waren
übrigens auch weil dieses gelände wenn
du so richtig autonom testen willst
musst du ein auf den zentimeter
vermessenes gelände haben damit die
gps-daten die karten alles den weg
vernünftig finden die brauchen dann
nämlich keine weißen linien ja und das
ist auf der schwäbischen alb glaube ich
schwierig
dürfen diese testautos auch privat
genutzt werden oder was spricht dafür
dass es keine testfahrt sondern eine
privatfahrt war naja es ist also wir
sind ja hier im normalen leben und
natürlich nehmen testfahrers nehmen
übrigens auch solche autos die es
vielleicht noch gar nicht gibt in diesem
fall gibt es das auto ja schon aber es
wird ja immer weiter getestet und
modernisiert also in dem fall nehmen
durchaus leute das wochenende das auto
übers wochenende oder über ein abend mit
nach hause und am nächsten morgen müssen
sie einen langen bericht schreiben was
das auto alles gemacht hat oder welche
fehlermeldungen kamen die sind meistens
vollgestopft auf der beifahrerseite mit
viel technik die haben auch alle so
einen großen roten knopf im auto das in
not knopf mit dem man das ding komplett
abschalten kann sofort falls etwas
schiefgeht
ich habe jetzt nicht in das auto rein
gucken können deswegen kann ich nicht
sehen aber ja im alltag neben dir das
auto natürlich mit und die haben eine
zulassung die sind auch immer versichert
diese autos natürlich auf deutsche
straßen bewegt sich kein auto was nicht
zugelassen ist und auch nicht versichert
ist haben wir halt ausnahmegenehmigung
jetzt tom könnte ja ein solcher unfall
wie dieser hier auf der schwäbischen alb
sozusagen der blick auch in die unfall
zukunft sein wir schauen einmal auf die
schuldfrage in einem solchen fall du
hast diesen uba unfall von damals schon
angesprochen angenommen das ist autonom
gefahren dort im testbetrieb und jetzt
stirbt eben dort ein mann bei diesem
unfall neun menschen werden verletzt
darunter ein anderthalb jahre altes
mädchen und wer es jetzt schuld der
fahrer der dort die technik überrumpeln
hätte müssen eingreifen müssen oder
sitzt der schuldige in der bmw zentrale
in ein dass es durchaus geregelt wir
haben ja in deutschland inzwischen diese
regelung dass du auf level 3 in
deutschland auf allen deutschen autobahn
kilometern über 13.000 kilometern darfst
du bist 60 stufe 3 fahren das heißt
wirklich hände vom lenkrad und füße von
den pedalen trotzdem muss der fahrer
eingreifen können im notfall aber das
fahrzeug kann sich dann sehr
selbstständig bewegen aber wir haben ja
die hybride welt in der sich viele
menschen lieben nicht so bewegen und die
frage ist kann das auto das schon und
hier ist es in dem fall auf jeden fall
bei der schuldfrage immer so dass der
fahrer eingreifen muss der fahrer hat
die verantwortung also schuld ist da das
auto selbst an dem punkt sind wir noch
nicht da müssen wir das liebesspiel bald
fragen wenn da mal wieder einen film
dreht das dauert noch ein bisschen aber
noch nicht dass das wird nicht abgegeben
moment ist es wirklich derjenige der das
fahrzeug in händen hat und führt der
dann die verantwortung trägt
[Musik]